have you ever wondered what Disney
Princesses might look like in another
youniverse
we just can't get enough of Disney so
we've took your favorite princesses and
put them in a completely new world stay
tuned to see what Elsa would look like
as well if you are new here hit that
subscribe button to never miss another
video and don't forget to give us a big
thumbs up here are 10 Disney Princesses
reimagined in parallel universes Moana
as Morita now this would be a very
interesting combination both Moana and
Marie two have a lot in common
their names both start with them but
they have also both been praised for
being the unconventional Disney
Princesses that have realistic morals
and unique stories neither Moana nor
Morita end up with a prince and that's
totally okay it's why we think these two
could actually play each other pretty
well here's Moana in Morita's universe
if you ever wanted to see Moana with
fiery red hair you should check this out
she's also rockin Morita's bow and arrow
along with her medieval dress the two
might come from different eras but their
stories are some of the most unique
Disney Princess stories we have ever
seen and from the looks of it Moana
would be totally fine in Marita's world
both of their body types were designed
to be realistic and go against the
traditional princesses which is exactly
why we love them both we have a feeling
Moana would do just fine in Marita's
world
speaking of Moana did you know that the
original story focused on Maui and Moana
was just a secondary character who is
supposed to save her love interest we're
so happy the creators of the movie
decided to go with something different
hey guys we are so excited to announce
we're producing our
original content head over to the trendy
for the best DIYs fashion tips makeup
hacks and so much more we are sure
you're going to love it Cinderella as
Mulan Cinderella and Mulan look like
they're worlds apart but according to
our own illustrations Cinderella would
actually do just fine in Milan's world
did you know that Cinderella is 19 while
Mulan is just 16 despite that both had
to go through plenty of hardships and
didn't really have an easy life which is
why we can definitely see Cinderella
take on Milan's role check her out we
left her with her iconic hair and her
blue headband and added mulan's typical
clothing we have to admit it's not her
favorite look but Cinderella would make
it her own it definitely looks like it
would have taken a while for Cinderella
to adjust to this role but we're sure
she'd be able to after all just like
Mulan Cinderella was used to being
mistreated but do you think she'll be
able to handle being around absolutely
no magic at all we'd love to see
Cinderella kick some butt using Milan's
moves although we're pretty sure she'd
have a hard time handling a sword did
you know that Cinderella is Walt
Disney's favorite heroine he admitted it
to the woman who voiced Cinderella in
the original movie we're pretty sure a
lot of you disagree so make sure to let
us know who's your favorite princess and
why in the comments below
Pocahontas as Cinderella Pocahontas and
Cinderella might be similar in age but
that's also the only thing they have in
common
out of all Disney Princesses the two
really seem like they are completely
different from each other we can't even
imagine Cinderella in Pocahontas world
but let's check out what Pocahontas
might look like as Cinderella we think
she's seriously rocking this look
Cinderella's iconic blue dress really
does fit her and she looks absolutely
stunning Pocahontas is clothing always
reflected her culture so seeing her in a
gown that's totally out of her era is
definitely interesting although we're
pretty sure Pocahontas would get bored
and Cinderella's role we feel like this
might actually work what do you think is
she able to pull it off we all know
Pocahontas is the only Native American
Disney Princess but did you know she
actually wasn't the first although she's
not an official Disney Princess the
title of the first Native American
Disney Princess belongs to princess
Tiger Lily from Peter Pan
Pocahontas is also the only Disney
princess with a tattoo even though there
are plenty of unconventional princesses
who came after her can you imagine
Ella with ink on her body we're pretty
sure that if Pocahontas would actually
become Cinderella she would take matters
into her own hands and make sure her
stepmother and stepsisters never boss
her around again no magic needed jasmine
as Ariel some of our favorite Disney
Princesses live in a completely
different world and we could never
imagine them being able to adapt to
another universe but the pair that we do
see together is Jasmine and Ariel
although jasmine is the second youngest
Disney Princess Ariel is not that much
older the two also share a similar
personality and we're pretty sure
jasmine would be able to play Ariel
story just as well check out what she
looked like
as Ariel doesn't she look gorgeous
Jasmine's style just got upgraded with a
mermaid tail and Ariel's shell bra
she's definitely rocking it and we all
know jasmine can be just as feisty and
headstrong as Ariel both of them even
found their true love at such a young
age they definitely have plenty of
similarities even though their stories
and their worlds are completely
different
however jasmine listens to her father a
bit more than Ariel does so we wonder
how that would play out in this scenario
jasmine sure looks like she'd be an
amazing mermaid doesn't she we already
know that Jasmine upgraded Aladdin's
look after Jasmine's character was first
illustrated the team had to go back and
upgrade Aladdin scruffy look do you
think they'd upgrade anyone if Jasmine
showed up in Ariel's world Ariel as
Aurora look at this illustration isn't
it neat although Aurora and Ariel shared
the first letter of their name and their
age they are completely different types
of characters sure they both end up with
the person they love but their journeys
are completely different we're really
not sure how the two would get along and
we're positive Ariel would get bored of
her Disney princess role if she was to
be cursed to sleep forever but you can't
deny that
Ariel looks totally gorgeous in Aurora's
beautiful blue dress we have seen plenty
of Disney Princesses Rock in their blue
dresses but we have to admit that
Aurora's dress is our favorite and we
love it even more on Ariel she looks
absolutely stunning and out of all
pairings we're showing you today this
one has to be our favorite if you saw
our other Disney videos you probably
know plenty of facts on the Little
Mermaid did you know that her name
Lion of God in Hebrew she's also the
only Disney princess that wasn't born
human and her quirky mannerisms actually
came from her live-action model which
means the original Ariel could end up
being a lot calmer and definitely not as
charming as the Ariel we know do you
prefer Ariel or Aurora make sure you let
us know in the comments Mulan has
outside
although Anna and Elsa from the movie
frozen aren't your typical Disney
Princesses and haven't gained the
princess title we're adding them to our
list we think it'd be interesting to see
some of the other princesses in the
frozen universe so here's what Mulan
would look like as Elsa we're not sure
how she would deal with the cold but we
can't imagine she'd make a great use of
Elsa's powers check her out this is what
Mulan would look like with Elsa's blond
hair color the blue dress definitely
suits her but we have to say we prefer
her regular dark color although it's
safe to say that Mulan would definitely
rule the world of frozen without any
issues but then again we'd probably
never get songs like do you want to
build a snowman
this would definitely be an interesting
thing to see even though we have to say
it's one of the oddest combinations yet
speaking of Mulan did you know she
shares similarities with another Disney
Princess
Mulan singing voice belongs to Leia
Salonga who also sings Jasmine's parts
in Aladdin and although both Mulan and
Elsa have pretty horrifying original
stories
Mulan could probably catch a much-needed
break if she would play the queen of
arendelle she can keep her gorgeous
original dark hair though Elsa as Tiana
so let's take another look at Elsa's
world but this time we'll see what she
looks like
as Tiana now this would be a very
interesting scenario because the two
really don't have anything in common
in fact Elsa is even a few years older
than Tiana even though The Princess and
the Frog heroine seems like she's a lot
more mature but it looks like Elsa could
easily fit in Tiana's universe check
this out she looks absolutely gorgeous
in the iconic green dress which is also
one of our favorite movie dresses Elsa
kept her long blonde hair but in our
version she definitely looks like a
brand new character what do you think
could Elsa pull off living in Tiana's
world we can't even imagine her working
in a restaurant and controlling her
temper
by the end everything would actually be
frozen Elsa was actually originally
designed to be a villain before she
became the main character of the movie
and did you
that there's another universe that
actually managed to cross over to frozen
you can see Rapunzel and Flynn and
Elsa's coronation
maybe this parallel universe thing isn't
such an odd idea after all
do you prefer Elsa or tiana we
definitely love this version of Elsa in
Tiana's world Aurora as jasmine here's
another interesting combination make
sure to keep on watching to catch the
mind-blowing facts about Aurora jasmine
is one of the youngest princesses but
Aurora is just one year older did you
have extremely different personalities
Aurora is shy polite and she's never
hurt a fly meanwhile jasmine speaks her
mind and there's a lot more confident
Aurora would have quite a challenge in
front of her if she'd ever become
Jasmine here's what that would actually
look like we thought we'd put her in
Jasmine's outfit and see what she'd do
see she already has a different attitude
and we're completely in love with this
look the blue really suits it and we bet
she could totally pull it off although
we're sure it would take Aurora a while
to step out of her shell and speak her
mind it would be a nice addition to the
iconic princess we bet she wouldn't mind
being around Aladdin either besides if
Aurora played jasmine she'd have a lot
more lines in the actual movie did you
know that Aurora only has 18 lines and
was soon onscreen for only 18 minutes
and yet she still became a Disney
princess while some of the other Disney
characters are still waiting to receive
that title
come on Aurora you can do better than 18
lines Ariel is Pocahontas
speaking of completely opposite Disney
Princesses Ariel and Pocahontas are also
an interesting pair one is 16 and one is
18 the two leaves completely different
lives and love is the only thing they
have in common and of course the throw
for an adventure and the desire to not
live a conventional life Pocahontas is
story is much more complicated than
Ariel's and we're not sure if Ariel
would be able to cope in Pocahontas
world here's what she'd look like this
is our favorite combination we're
showing you today and she looks
absolutely adorable first of all we love
Ariel with dark hair but we also love
how her big eyes really add a cartoon
element to her look she almost looks
like a Bratz doll she looks extremely
good at Pocahontas his signature dress
and we bet she wouldn't even miss having
a mermaid tail after all she is
fascinated by feet Ariel would clearly
play Pocahontas without any issues well
at least in theory
speaking of Ariel did you know that she
was the first Disney Princess with a
go-getter attitude
these Disney Princesses have all had the
typical gentle outlook on life while
Ariel was definitely a lot more carefree
and of course Pocahontas only took that
attitude even further the two would
definitely be an interesting pair but we
feel like Ariel would have way more fun
in Pocahontas is world Elsa as Belle
since
Elsa isn't an official Disney Princess
we thought she deserves more spotlight
so here's another version of what she'd
look like in the world of an actual
princess this time we've paired her up
with Belle while Elsa is definitely the
older one Belle has a lot more freedom
and seems to absorb more knowledge as
she reads her adored books
we're pretty sure Elsa would turn the
Beauty and the Beast Castle into the
same castle we see in frozen if she ever
entered Belle's universe
here's what she looked like surprisingly
Elsa can actually rock dark hair along
with Belle's gorgeous yellow dress
she'd totally pulled us off and we bet
she'd be a bit more strong headed then
Belle and get rid of Gaston a lot
earlier what do you think can you see
the queen of arendelle being transported
to a tiny French village and read every
single book she can get she'd probably
develop her powers out of sheer boredom
we have to admit this look totally suits
her speaking of frozen have you ever
noticed the hidden secrets from the
movie the credit state that the Walt
Disney Company does not support the
consumption of boogers and that all
opinions expressed by Kristoff are
solely his own the names right above the
disclaimer are credits - all crew
members kids born during the production
of the movie pretty cool right not as
cool as also in Belle's world that's it
for tag Disney Princesses reimagined in
parallel universes for more videos like
this one check out 15 Disney Princesses
reimagined by amazing artists see you
next time
[Music]